and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber the state of South
Carolina called its Final witness on
Friday wrapping up weeks of testimony in
the Alec Murdoch murder trial the last
witness was able to offer some
clarification on where Murdoch was in
the night his wife and son were killed
updated GPS information from Murdoch's
phone and car helps lay out his location
on June 7th 2021 so let's get a little
into it Murdoch left the family's
country estate Moselle to visit his
ailing mother just after 9 pm he spent
about 20 minutes there before heading
back home he got back to the main house
at 10 then headed to this the state's
dog kennels at 1005 and just about one
minute later he found his wife Maggie
and Son Paul shot dead at the kennels
and then called 9-1-1 at 1006. now he
told police that he went back to the
main house to get a gun just in case
before meeting them at the kennels now
despite Murdoch insisting to
investigators that he wasn't out at the
kennels before visiting his mother at
least eight Witnesses have tested that
they heard his voice on a video that
Paul took at the kennels at around 8 45
PM the prosecution has pinned much of
its case on discrediting Murdoch's Alibi
and proving he's a liar the state
alleges that Murdoch killed Maggie and
Paul to try to shift attention away from
Financial crimes as well as his as well
as his opioid use on Friday an
investigator revealed a voicemail that
Paul left his father in the months
before the murders letting him know that
Maggie found some of his drugs
and this is a text from from which
person to which person so this is going
to be from Paul murdaugh and it's going
to be to it says voicemail that's going
to refer to Alex this is obtained from
his phone it's gonna be the owner so
that's going to be Paul to Alex
and what's the date
the date is gonna be uh May 6 2021 at 10
52 13 A.M
and what does it say
it says I am still an EB because when
you get here we need to talk mom found
several bags of pills in your computer
bag
this is again from Paul to Alex
on May 6. this is going to be a Google
searches
um far left you're going to have a time
stamp
the source which is going to be Safari
that's for Apple
and then the value is going to be the
searched item and on May 26 2021 at 11
21 PM Maggie searched green gel pill P30
she also searched
um
11 20 p.m a green pill a green gel pill
P30
white pill 30 on one side RP and if you
look to the right you're going to see a
comma says deleted that one is showing
yes has been deleted
and then if we go down to row number
four
it's going to be May 6 2021 from Safari
white pill 30 on one side RP and that's
also shown deleted
to bring my co-host Terry Austin Brian
buckmeyer Terry I'll start with you so
we hear this testimony again about the
roadside shooting right this apparent
suicide attempt by Murdoch a few months
after the murders some of the
cross-examination was a bit fiery what
do you think the jury took away from
that well yeah Jesse that was special
agent Kelly and he talked about that
roadside shooting and it was feisty I
thought that Kelly was very respectful
but Harpoon I think on the
cross-examination he was very
condescending he was argumentative there
were a couple of objections there and I
think all in all Kelly was able to
establish that the 911
made basically he said someone else did
it some unknown suspect and if you think
about it even though that shooting was
after the murders there is some
connection maybe he's trying to say that
this unknown suspect was trying to kill
him and trying to or did kill his wife
and son so I definitely think it was
relevant well Brian the big highlight
was they the prosecution ends the day
with this really detailed timeline was
that strategic to end that way and by
the way I imagine the jury gets a print
out of that yeah I would think so as
well gives them a road map when they're
done and deliberating but I think it's
for two reasons uh one it's a great way
to kind of get two bites of the Apple if
you thought that this testimony kind of
felt or sounded like a summation it
probably did and they're gonna be able
to do the same thing at the end of the
defense's case and actually give their
their summation two lawyers are taught
how to make arguments and prosecutors
prosecutors love a good structured
argument I don't want to give anyone
PTSD who's gone to law school but it's
Iraq it's issue rule application and
conclusion I know I can hear you already
Jesse but that's what it is it's the
conclusion to really tie up their
arguments you just give me a chill I
just felt like I was a 1l yeah black
acre we'll go back to that too
[Music]
and welcome back everybody week two is
wrapping up in Broward County Florida
for the murder trial of rising rap
artist xxxtentacion so far we learned
some key evidence against the
co-defendants and if all goes to plan
one of hip-hop's artists biggest names
is going to be giving a deposition next
week Michael Boatwright Trayvon Newsom
and Diedrich Williams face a life in
prison for the 2018 robbery that killed
20 year old Jose on Freud the victim was
driving out of a motorcycle dealership
when prosecutors say boat right and
Newsome jumped out of an SUV that
Williams was driving and approached on
Freud the two men there shot the rap
artist and took his designer bag with
fifty thousand dollars cash inside a
fourth co-defendant Robert Allen
testified for five days about the murder
he says he was in the SUV when the
murder took place and acted as an
informant he took a plea deal for a
possibly reduced sentence and that
sentencing date is now scheduled for
next Thursday but behind the scenes
Williams defense attorney fought to have
hip-hop artist Drake give a damn
position Drake's attorney fought back
saying that rumor and innuendo of a
conspiracy isn't a good enough reason to
question him he also claimed that the
notice was filed incorrectly the judge
told Williams defense attorney to refile
the notice and the deposition is now
scheduled for next Friday now let's
rewind a little bit back to this Friday
where we heard from an employee at the
motorcycle dealership he described the
robbery from his van vantage point but
couldn't make out important details
about the Suspects
I saw the person
over Ms Osprey holding the
rifle gun whatever it was it was a short
it was a short uh
it wasn't like a long rifle okay so
possibly a short barrel rifle that you
can see and I saw him you know
struggling struggling reaching in
reaching into the car uh the other
gentleman also reaching reaching and
then I heard the gunshots okay thank you
how many gunshots did you hear I think I
did three and which side of the vehicle
were the gunshots coming from it was on
the left side of the driver's side the
driver's side now what were the physical
descriptions of the two gentlemen
starting with the one that was holding
the what you described as a rifle I saw
it uh
one one gentleman was definitely a
larger frame than the other gentleman
that you know that ran him on the
passenger side of the car were you able
to tell from your Vantage Point what the
race was of the shooter no were you able
to see what race the second person was
that was on the other side of the BMW
the passenger side what if anything was
um on their face or their head that
obstructed your view I really I really
couldn't see they were wearing full
clothes like they were wearing masks I
couldn't tell what nationality they were
Brian let's say the defense gets
strike's deposition and how do they use
it at a trial Jesse I'm thinking not
very well at all let's imagine this
Drake takes a deposition right he comes
and he testifies and I don't think
there's gonna be a huge Smoking Gun
where he says I'm the one who planned
this murder no it's going to be I Didn't
Do It plead the fifth I don't have any
connection to that this is just rap so
then the prosecution has all that
information and if the defense tries to
ring that Bell again the def the
prosecution gets to hit them over the
head with Drake's testimony and they
look like a liar and making fanciful uh
claims in front of the jury that's the
quickest way for you to lose it's way
better to argue the quote-unquote empty
chair Drake's not here we can't ask him
questions we don't know this we don't
know that that's a stronger argument
than actually getting him to pose I
think it's a foolish step by the defense
well Terry let's focus on the evidence
uh that was presented by the prosecution
do you think that any of the remaining
three defendants has any chance of being
acquitted a murder here yeah not at all
they're not going to be acquitted listen
you have the prosecution who has video
for goodness sakes and they have Alan
testifying you know he took a plea deal
so we definitely have some evidence
against the defendants as far as you
know what we said Allen is saying but I
think also the witness who came on the
stand today he's corroborating now he
doesn't know a lot of details but he is
still collaborating what Alan said and
you know we don't know what's going to
happen at the end of the day but we do
know that the defendants they're just
pointing the finger at other people
they're saying Drake did it they're
saying that the investigation was shoddy
they're saying everything else but they
cannot really defend themselves not
surprised given the gravity of the
evidence against them they're going to
be saying something it might not be the
best defense but it's something